hey youtubers is Charlie Justice League
trailer around the corner we got a
little teaser so let's break it down
there are actually people that got to
visit this set so we know what's going
on here new trailer on the way means new
giveaway so all you have to do to enter
the flash ring giveaway is just be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything so
what's going on why are they dropping
this the week of Christmas well there
was a rumor that they were gonna drop a
trailer around the release of Ben
Affleck's new movie live by night which
he stars in with Gamora so as is the
style of Studios they drop like
increasing teasers in size like they
drop a really small teaser then they
drop a little bit of footage then they
drop like the full big trailer so do not
be surprised if they drop more footage
tomorrow too but what's going on in this
picture is it's actually like a
parademon nest in this big ventilation
tower that they have to use one of
Batman's new special tanks to get up
into at least everybody but the flash so
a bunch of people got to visit the set
of Justice League last year like where
they were filming a lot of these scenes
that you see in the behind the scenes
trail that they released a while ago and
they got a look at this big Batman
spider-man type looking vehicle just
made for climbing walls so a lot of you
have guessed that because they're gonna
be fighting a ton of parademons this
photo is from them just looking at a
nest of parademons getting ready for a
huge action set piece so I wouldn't be
surprised if that's part of the trailer
they end up releasing really soon like
the previous trailer was really just
like a couple of bits of Batman going
around recruiting the team but they'd
only been filming for a couple weeks
when they cut that trailer together for
Comic Con like even the CG wasn't
finished like it was all just very work
print so the stuff we're getting ready
to see like the scene that they're
teasing right here is this going to be
way more polished so we haven't actually
gotten a look for with the actual
parademons in the movie look like but
just look at how Batman's costume has
evolved a little bit he's super freakin
jacked even the flash and Wonder Woman's
costumes have been tweaked a little bit
the flash costume is actually pretty
interesting because like you look at it
here it looks a little bit more polished
in this but in the previous trailers it
seemed kind of cobbled together so the
way that Zack Snyder and the producers
have explained it is that
this version of the flash this version
of Barry Allen has been on his own he's
been keeping his power secret trying to
help people but because he's a scientist
he actually is able to cobble together a
suit that protects him at super speed
but because advanced materials like that
are so hard to come by without access to
like a giant science team and millions
and millions of dollars that he later
gets from Bruce Wayne until he gets to
that point he has to dumpster dive to
construct his suit so it's made from the
pieces of fallen spacecraft and
satellites really advanced materials
that are made to withstand super high
temperatures super high speeds so Bruce
Wayne gets the files from Amanda Waller
at the end of Suicide Squad
this is crown jewels him mr. Wayne and
you do understand my legal exposure if
anyone knew what I procured for you
listen I can keep a secret okay what do
you want people are asking questions
about Midway city the kind of people can
get the answers and if they can get
those answers my head will be on a pike
consider yourself under my protection if
you deliver
[Music]
why mr. Wayne just like to make friends
it's the difference between those who
believe in friendship I believe in the
leverage good night
you look tired should stop working
nights you should shut it down my
friends and I'll do it for you and then
goes out recruiting finds very element
they have this scene here in the Justice
League trail that we've already seen
persuade you said that like it explains
why there's a total stranger sitting in
the dark in my second favorite chair
look man I don't know who you are but
whoever you're looking for
so you're fast that feels like an
oversimplification I'm putting together
a team of people with special abilities
see I believe enemies are coming stop
right there I'm in you are just like
that yeah I need friends right keep this
and then Batman brings him on the team
Tony Stark style gives them a
top-to-bottom redesign or really just
kind of polishes the suit it's not as
big of a change is spider-man pre Tony
Stark to pose Tony Stark like the stark
tech spider-man suit is so much more
advanced than the hoodie that Spiderman
was running around in but it's a lot of
the same energy except that this version
of Barry Allen is just quite a bit older
like it's a much more adult version of
Barry on even older than the version on
the TV show right now so the funny thing
about new flash movies suit is that
Grant Gustin has been teasing that Barry
Allen on the TV show needs a new suit
I'll totally do a future flash new
costume video later this week there'll
be some new flash season 3 but just part
of the joy of a comic book movie and a
new big team-up is the fact that you get
new shiny awesome suits even Wonder
Woman looks like she's been polishing
her suit and in addition to that they've
also been tuning the color just a little
bit more like you go from this really
bleak period during Batman V Superman
they drained a lot of the color out of
that movie which is why it looks so dark
just like the way they edited the film
in post-production but we get to Justice
League things are a little bit more
hopeful people are inspired by
Superman's sacrifice so in addition to
wearing shinier cooler looking costumes
they also start turning the color up in
post-production so the film itself just
seems brighter more colorful and then we
can all start guessing about what's
gonna happen when Superman eventually
comes back but I think the idea is is
that by the end of Justice League when
he's finally defeated Steppenwolf it'll
be a super bright super hopeful like God
has returned to earth and they are now a
fully
actualise team together but that says
nothing about what their adventure in
the second Justice League movie is going
to be and they postponed that you may
have heard about this they postponed the
second Justice League movie by about a
year or so to make room for Ben
Affleck's Batman movie so that's still a
ways out but Warner Brothers brought in
like a brand new creative person that's
sort of overseeing a lot of the film
stuff with Geoff Johns and he said the
Batman movie is coming at 2018 it'll
probably be like a spring movie most
Batman movies are early summer late
spring so it'll probably be the same
thing for Ben Affleck's new movie which
is still called the Batman so just to
reiterate what's probably going to be
happening this week is is that because
the trailer for Justice League is
supposed to be coming out around
Christmas time and we're only a couple
days away from that they'll probably do
that thing where they dropped a tiny bit
of footage like hey there's a trailer
coming tomorrow and then you know
whatever day after that it'll just come
tomorrow so really I just recommend that
you be on alert anytime between the 24th
in the 26th the 26th is on a Monday so
that sounds pretty reasonable for them
dropping a trailer most trailers tend to
drop during the weekdays but because Ben
Affleck's movies opening this weekend
they might drop it ahead of that movie
so who knows just the on high alert for
the rest of the week so as long as
you've enabled alerts for my channel you
should be totally fine there'll be a
bunch more flash DC stuff happening this
week as well as Marvel stuff there's
probably going to be some more stuff
like this from the other studios but
like last year we had the 12 days of
Deadpool obviously they're not gonna do
that this year so because we don't have
that I'm doing my epic battles videos
like I just did Justice League beating
the [ __ ] out of Suicide Squad so if you
want to suggest an epic battles bonus
video just write it below in the
comments like Superman vs Deathstroke is
gonna be one of the next ones that I'll
do and for all you Rick and Morty fans
out there I actually got my hands on
some new Rick and Morty season 3 footage
so I'll post that tomorrow morning so
Christmas week just continues to deliver
shiny new things wait you guys wait for
that to post you can click here to watch
the Justice League beat the crap out of
the Suicide Squad and you can click here
to watch the flash fight iris West
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys